putin kumpel gerhard schröder der
ex-kanzler er fliegt nicht aus der spd
die spd will ihnen auch weiter als
mitglied haben das hat die
schiedskommission der sozialdemokraten
in hannover heute entschieden schröder
habe so heißt es sich heißt es in der
begründung habe sich eines verstoßes
gegen die partei ordnung nicht schuldig
gemacht da ihn kein verstoß nachzuweisen
sei bild meinem chef philippe piatti 4
im studio bei bild live grüße dich
phillip kein verstoß gegen die partei
regularien gerhard schröder bleibt in
der partei wenn es nicht ausreicht
werbung für wladimir putin zu machen
seine interessen zu vertreten den mann
der
kriegsverbrechen begeht aktuell tag für
tag und mit fliegt man dann raus bei der
spd ja der spd vorsitzende lars
klingbeil hat sich auch bereits geäußert
und gesagt das sei eine juristische
entscheidung aber politisch sei gerhard
schröder natürlich spd in der spd
isoliert ich frage mich wenn man es
aufgrund der partei ordnung nicht
schafft ein krimi lobbyisten
rauszuschmeißen vielleicht sollte man
dann ein seine partei ordnung dann gehen
denn die spd sieht sich ja seit
jahrzehnten als brandmauer gegen rechts
fordert von der union die ganze zeit
dass man sich abgrenzt so gut es geht zu
afd oft auch zu recht aber warum grenzt
man sich denn nicht selbst ab von dem
regime das also von einem russischen
regime das in ganz europa rechtsextreme
parteien finanziert denn für dieses
regime arbeitet gerhard schröder und
zwar seit vielen vielen jahren deswegen
jetzt einfach nur zu sagen ja juristisch
ist das schwierig das reicht mir nicht
das ist ein regierungspartei die kann
ein kreml lobbyisten nicht dulden hat
die spd alles versucht ihn raus zu
kriegen
das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen dass
die spd weiß ja seit vielen jahren dass
schröder für putin arbeitet seit 2005
ist er so ist es zumindest offiziell
bekannt im dienst von wladimir putin und
jetzt erst hat man gemerkt hoppla das
mit dem krieg sieht jetzt ganz doof für
ihn aus der zeit der druck zugenommen da
hat man dieses verfahren eben dann
angestrengt das jetzt durch die
schiedskommission entschieden wurde gas
gerd bleibt spd-mitglied er darf sein
parteibuch behalten heißt aber auch
schröder zuletzt im großen interview im
stern vor allen dingen sich selber
geschadet ab jetzt schadet er wieder
umso mehr auch seine spd den
sozialdemokraten insgesamt ja wobei ich
glaube der punkt bei schröder ist dass
er gerade deutschland schadet und auch
das sollte die spd in den blick nehmen
das stern interview von gerhard schröder
war ein ganz gezielte angriff des kreml
auf die bundesregierung ist unter dieser
angriff wurde durchgeführt von einem
wichtigen lobbyisten von gerhard
schröder das ziel ist es olaf scholz
anzugreifen dem spd kanzler seine
position lächerlich zu machen seine
position zu untergraben um deutschland
in diesem kampf zu schwächen dafür steht
gerhard schröder dafür bereit der spd
mitglied bleiben vorerst muss man sagen
denn jetzt kann es natürlich in die
zweite instanz gehen diejenigen die das
die den rausschmiss von schröder
gefordert haben haben jetzt zwei wochen
zeit um nachzulegen um sich zu
beschweren über dieses urteil und damit
weiter verhandelt da könnte sich der spd
chef lars klingbeil selbst an die spitze
setzen und das eben versuchen das
zumindest wäre eine möglichkeit das zu
tun jetzt gucken wir nochmal in die
geschichte der spd wir wissen werde
rausgeflogen ist aus der partei also
thilo sarrazin zum beispiel das heißt
jetzt ganz simpel drauf geguckt thilo
sarrazin schlimmer für die spd weniger
verträglich als gerd schröder ja so
sieht es geradeaus und das finde ich
persönlich geradezu lächerlich und es
geht nicht darum wen man hier
sympathischer findet aber die tragweite
eines
streitbaren oder von mir aus
umstrittenen autors und die tragweite
eines kreml lobbyisten das sind zwei
unterschiedliche dimensionen der eine
schreibt bücher die
rassismus-vorwürfe kassiert haben der
andere arbeitet für ein kriegsverbrecher
regime und propagiert dessen positionen
in deutschland das sind unterschiedliche
dimensionen und dass die gesamte spd
sich jahrelang an sarrazin ab gekämpft
hat und man jetzt das sind kleine
schiedsgericht überlässt und der spd
vorsitzende lars klingbeil der früher
selbst für gerhard schröder gearbeitet
hat bei seiner hochzeit bei lars
klingbeil hochzeit war gertrud man hat
schröder jahrelang hofiert bis im
letzten jahr hat man ihn hofiert erst
jetzt mit dem pool mit putins
angriffskrieg hat man gesehen dass das
jetzt in der öffentlichkeit gar nicht
mehr geht aber die ganze partei stand
wirklich bis letztes jahr hinter ihm und
schaut jetzt auch immer noch weg danke
für deine wie immer klare meinung viele
pia tor für unser bild meinung chef hier
zum ja nicht parteiausschluss von gerd
schröder bei den sozialdemokraten heute
danke dir
[Musik]